here is the host of jeopardy
alex trebek
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of all of us welcome to
america's favorite answer in question
game
jeopardy here is the host
of jeffery alex
and family thank you johnny hi ladies
and gentlemen welcome to our show
kids had no school today so i promised
six-year-old emily and nine-year-old
matthew that they could attend a taping
of our show
alex 30 seconds
thank you john thank you yeah
[Music]
from the las vegas hilton here is the
host
of jeopardy
thank you john thank you very much thank
you ladies and gentlemen isn't it
amazing
how regular straight-laced people come
to las vegas
and suddenly do wild and crazy things
alex trevor
thank you very much johnny ladies and
[Music]
gentlemen
alex
thank you johnny gilbert
alex thank you johnny gilbert
ladies and gentlemen welcome to our show
i was informed backstage a few minutes
ago that our three contestants ken brad
and jerome wanted to relieve some of the
tension and they said we must do the
program
without trousers
now here is the host of jeopardy
any of you a regular competition
champion rolando
thank you mr president welcome to our
program so long everybody
i'm at post office bay on the island of
floriana
when sailors messages to their families
back home were intercepted right here
by u.s navy captain david porter and his
crew
they indicated the positions of their
ships
and that information helped destroy the
british pacific
whaling fleet during this war best one
for me
best one by far
new record for jeopardy congratulations
to you we're going to retire you
and we'll look for you next year on our
tournament of champions
charity it's gift of love hospice run by
the missionaries of charities it's a
teresa's order in new york city
well congratulations again frank and
thank you for tuning us in
three new contestants tomorrow we'll see
you then so long
dana venator what's the most notable
memory that you're going to take back to
georgia with you uh regarding this
tournament our hotel room is a very nice
hotel room
we took pictures of it is it that good
yeah we're going to buy the robe and
everything
it's a great time
well i'm glad i'm glad we met with your
approval and on that score
eddie congratulations you have 69
thousand
seven hundred dollars
great game a great week for you
congratulations
good game players my gosh
2 million 520 000
and change plus even better news
you picked up 2 000 for finishing in
second place
on yesterday's show
for me the greatest for me of all time
congratulations
congratulations hey way to go
let's take a look at your response did
you come up with the right one no
but it is we love you out that's very
kind thank you
costco 19.95
you're left with five bucks okay
and the emmy for outstanding game show
host
goes to alex trip back
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations thank you
ever since the nominations came out
i have worried about this moment
let me explain you were worried about
winning
yeah uh i was concerned
that sympathy might play a big role in
the voting
this year let me finish i'm not a big
fan of sympathy votes
i believe we should all be judged on the
merits of
our work however i started thinking back
to last year
last year i was nominated i had just had
major
surgery to remove two life-threatening
blood clots on my brain you would think
that would have elicited a certain
amount of sympathy
[Applause]
but i didn't win
so maybe maybe i've been worrying about
the wrong thing and i should just do
what sally field did in a different
venue many many years ago
and look at this as a sign that you guys
like me
and that you value my work
and i'll tell you
if that's the case i can live with that
thank you thank you
i wanted to be the one to pass along
this information now
just like fifty thousand other people in
the united states each year
this week i was diagnosed with stage
four pancreatic cancer
now normally the prognosis for this is
not very encouraging
but i'm going to fight this and i'm
going to keep working
and with the love and support of my
family and friends
and with the help of your prayers also
i plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease
truth told i have to because under the
terms of my contract
i have to host jeopardy for three more
years
so help me keep the faith and we'll win
we'll get it done thank you